elle aimait aller le 20 minutes médias
et on va parler aux de l'amour est dans
le pré
alors l'amour est dans le pré je crois
que j'ai vu l'image la plus drôle de
l'histoire de l'amour est dans le pré
hier bien entendu c'était dans le sauna
c'est jean-claude un agriculteur qui a
voulu faire kiffer sa dulcinée yolande a
du coup ils année à antibes et il a
prévu une petite séance repos dans un
jacuzzi
sauf que lui il sait repérer les
jacuzzis mais c'est pas monter dedans
car les médias plus de poils on fait
comment
âmes sensibles s'abstenir minuit vient
de sonner et l'heure est venue pour jc
d'exhiber à yolande à sa parade nuptiale
à poil
[Musique]
ou comment
je peux vous aider
est ce que vous trouvez que le montage
dénigrant sa drôle oui jean guillot oui
non il faut savoir que tous les
candidats sont ridicules en apparence ça
les rend extrêmement sympathique est
candidat oui et puis pour la production
c'est du pain béni non en télé on adore
les accidents quand rien ne se passe
comme prévu et si tout se passait
normalement dans l'amour et dans lequel
je pense que personne ne regardait donc
c'est top c'est vrai oui alors vous vous
dites vous oui je voulais absolument
c'est un principe c'est le principe de
l'émission c'est se moquer des
agriculteurs à leurs dépends une fois de
plus voilà c'est le sait c'est drôle oui
c'est un bêtisier mais ça me dérange à
chaque fois de paul ahyi nîmes l'agent
de joueurs savent bien que tu regarde de
temps en temps alors regarde je regarde
c'est tout le temps comme ça alors il
regagna une deuxième image là je vous
montrais dans l'émission a également vu
un slot entre jean claude et yolande a
visiblement jean-claude n'avait pas
l'air de trop qui fait un rappel en
voyant cet extrait l'abus d'alcool peut
être dangereux tu t'en fous
c'est ce que demande
oui mais j'ai compris j'ai compris en
corée sont souples eh oui arrive on y va
ça y est où là
deux tendances bas c'est un moment qui
ont faim les outrances de combrit
quelquefois j'ai besoin sans que
c'est pas au vallon on espère aller
quelque part où à moi je suis aussi
peut-être oui oui mais est-ce qu'on
pense qu'on pourrait peut être un jour
éventuellement être
pour l'instant j'ai encore parlé
il décrit justement là je trouve que ça
contredit un petit peu ce que ben viens
de dire oui là c'est pas lui qui en
porte à faux ca brive
elle s est plutôt rigolo c'est ce qui se
passe dans généralement dans la vraie
vie donc je vois pas ce qu'un jeu c'est
vrai que c'est la vie
oui bon choix en raccrochant dois dire
que c'est quand même une mission très
fête du slip
ouais m d'ailleurs je rappelle que la
fiducie pour a lieu du 15 au soir d'été
suivre mes portes ouvertes et slip ou
bear oui mais pas mal de sexe un peu
gaudriole c'est un peu potache on sent
que c'est en fait une édition post
confinement lancée d'hier m'ont dit
qu'ils ont malgré tout que les
agriculteurs sont très seuls
mais là en plus je pense qu'il ya besoin
ils ont besoin de un peu de frivolité et
le montage de tribunes étaient a été un
peu aussi d'en orienter dans ce sens un
chasseur la frivolité
mais j'ai l'impression que ma vie n'est
pas ma chérie comme est regardé comme
elle est belle tout fleurit la benne
durable qui on n'a plus qu'à la mettre
dans un vase mais je pense qu'on a cette
saison la plus belle histoire d'amour
née 15 saisons ravaux avec un garçon
splendide 0 rouen plus une femme
magnifique sans qu'une foule comme j'en
ai jamais vu vous adorez l'acteur robert
de niro mais ils analysent parle quand
même de sexualité les deux même si celle
racontée par 2,6 à témoin ses normes
étaient par la sexualité un enfant ça se
fait pas sans papa dans maman la bonne
et moi je suis d'accord et ça se fait
pas dans les choux la responsabilité est
énorme et ça ne mène à rien ben haim qui
te fait son grand retour après deux
jours non mais effectivement géraldine
appartement où on parle d'amour on parle
de dating en fin de rencontre il ya bien
un moment où on va aborder les choses
qui sont plus charnel tout computer
science sensuelles voire sexuelle
c'était l'idée moi que je trouve plutôt
sympathique c'est de le faire avec le
prisme de l'humour avec les petites
blagues à deux balles avec
éventuellement la petite voix etc
c'est pas gênant
mayrand simple femmes les rangs
sympathie moi c'est moi je rentre dedans
je suis je suis très premier degré je
suis très littérale est rien et que
j'aime dire belge à trouve très dur avec
lui pourquoi elle est si méchante mois
sur lui au contraire aucune étendre
qu'il est amoureux qui les lie match est
vraiment très premier degré sur cette
émission
alors il m'a dit cola pepsico mondiale
non moi je trouve que c'est une émission
très très bon enfant
évidemment le thème c'est l'amour donc
c'est normal qu'on ait assisté dans le
pré et puis ce sont deux solitudes qui
se rencontrent jeu ça très beau on voit
on sent là transept et seul vous moi je
suis seul mais vous savez jamais été
quelqu'un vous c'est vrai si mais pas
longtemps qu'on fait cinq six mois
chasseurs ils sont jaloux je vous en
êtes un monsieur à web mettez pas vos
cartouches partout
mais je rigolais quoi c'est vrai bernard
monte alors moi je suis là là
actuellement si vous voulez je n'aime
pas parler de ma vie privée mais je suis
seul déjà depuis pas mal de temps en
même temps là ça veut la vérité deux ans
non deux ans que cette seule non mais je
baise quand même
comme on dit je fais l'amour c'est pas
possible a fait l'amour tendrement voilà
un roman mais on l'a vu dans la presse
people koi avec des textes avec casimir
non mais moi j'aime la solitude en fait
je suis en train de l'apprivoiser parce
que quand on vit la solitude ben on est
envahis on est obligé de faire avec
alors moi les compromis les coupes qui
se savait genre en bresse non ça si
sérieuse qui veut d'ici salon reste
parce que il ya les enfants moi d'abord
j'ai pas d'enfant donc tant mieux et ça
coûtera moins cher et puis en plus comme
ça on peut changer plus souvent
oui j'ai coupé ton téléphone non mais
c'est pas opposé mais ce que tu
recherches quelqu'un bernard nom étant
non rester ça juste un coup c'est les
sous-vêtements rigoler mais quoi un coup
comme on dit alors alors une aventure
une aventure dernièrement
non non enfin si non quoi et qui dit
nous perdrons tienne c'est quoi le plus
longtemps avec ta grand mère
[Rires]
mais j'aime c'est la meilleure voie
d'autres tableaux toi ta grand mère et
ta grandeur et vous êtes resté le même
temps six en cinq ans quatre ans mais je
soumets trois ans bah oui lesquelles has
63 wh msf au fait vous en fait mr jeu
magnifique dit le savons en revanche
[Rires]
c'est vrai il est magnifique d'abonnés
magnifique
donc oui il préférait rester seul ouais
vraiment vous n'êtes pas peur de
vieillir seul parce que vous êtes mais
si vous êtes debout non non non non ça
commence à tirer le matin au chu c'est
compliqué je vois ma tête c'est
difficile
non ce qui me fait chier quand on en
sort ici on est une bande c'est sympa on
rigole on essaie divertir le public
d'abord mais après ils devront tout seul
à la maison et je sais pas faire la
bouffe n'ont donc alors je mange des
trucs tout la triste puisque c'est un
choix mais il faut se taper quoi vous
mettez pas que daniel moreau qui est
seul aussi vous voulez que je me casse
tout de suite j'adore daniel dhumeaux
mais c'est pas faire la bouffe tout cas
merci film chercher à cuisiner mais
savez-vous ce mec là on est serrés bouge
espère y trouver chaussure à votre pied
ou bien c'était les gammes en dise voilà
m c'est vrai oui c'est ces jours ci un
autre carole imbert votre casserole un
dentier à votre on va voir ce qu'en
pensent ses téléspectateurs qu'ils aient
de quoi pour les candidats et il dérange
ou non à 58 sur 100 les